[Music]
anybody here kevin spacey fan oh yeah i
love him why are you accountable
after the allegations i became a real
big fan of them oh you weren't before no
no
okay you like post allegations kevin
spence oh he's the best he's the best
the house of cards after the allegations
came out she got better yeah so much
better i mean his character did become
more real you know what i after all that
[ __ ] went down the house of cards
started sucking for me but i don't think
it's because of kevin spacey i actually
think it's because of trump because real
politics was way more [ __ ]
entertaining than true the drama
politics yeah they're like you're making
it too real
kevin spacey pleads not guilty
to all sexual assault charges
he wasn't he was being um like like what
are you calling just entered a plea of
not guilty to sexual charge it's
criminal assault charges at the old
bailly yeah the 62 year old hollywood
actor winner of two academy awards is
accused of sexual assault on several
charges dating back 17 years
just catch people up he quote
strenuously denies the allegations made
against him by three men who are now in
their 30s and 40s
spacey appeared at the court under his
full name kevin spacey fowler having
been granted unconditional bail ahead of
proceedings he spoke to confirm his name
and date of birth before openly denying
the four charges of sexual assault and
one of causing a person to engage in
penetrative sexual activity without
consent
i.e rape that's right are all three of
those uh accusers
actors because i know one of them was
are all three of them like famous people
i heard some of the accusers were ended
up dead was that like just
ended up dead yeah
was that a rumor after they were accused
yeah after the accusations this wasn't
there they didn't say it remember that
was a story that was being pushed around
i don't know if this was confirmed if
they end up dead then that means the
case is dropped for that person right
yeah i think i don't know i didn't know
there was multiple accusers for this one
the incidents relating to the charges
took place in london and glaucestershire
between 2005 and 2013 during a period of
time forced lipping a man when spacey
was the artistic director of the old vic
theater in london and he was at a party
and he
allegedly
did it with the underage boy jesus
christ wait he actually like did it
i thought he was just like trying to
seduce the kid into doing it
sounds like i ain't trying to spread
rumors but that's what i remember
they use words like engage in
penetrative sexual activity without
consent
of a boy okay i don't know i'm just
saying you know what i mean that's like
a legal term yeah he doesn't like girls
at all the charges include two counts of
sexual assault on a man who is now in
his 40s allegedly taking place in march
2005 in london
as well as another alleged sexual
assault on a man now in his 30s and
causing him to engage in penetrative
sexual activity without consent in
august 2008 in london
and a third count of sexual assault on a
man now in his 30s in glad chestershire
during april 2013. so those are the
the the charges that are in question
isn't one of those guys like one of the
kids from adventures in babysitting that
movie from the 80s and then he ended up
being in rent the movie in the 90s
oh which means he wasn't a kid by the
time he was assaulted is what you're
saying though no no no he that happened
when he was a kid and then he
recollected it and then like brought it
up and went like oh actually kevin
spacey's like a piece of [ __ ] because
when i was a kid he tried to [ __ ] me in
this room
and that's what started the [ __ ] but
this guy's like older now oh i don't
know if that's what started that's the
first one i heard of yeah is there a
possibility at all that he's innocent or
everyone just knows that he's guilty as
[ __ ] because of all the people that came
out
he probably well if you listen to cancel
culture
he shouldn't even have a trial because
his accusers told all and that's it yeah
that's that's all you need to hear how
do you normally collect evidence with
something that happened so long ago like
this you can't no idea these things are
[ __ ] unless you have it in like video
or whatever unless you have like a black
book that nobody gets to look into a
list hashtag show us the list the fact
that kevin spacey was attached to
epstein and glenn maxwell raises a lot
of eyebrows to a lot of people i think
the most in the public eye because of
that kevin spacey's already [ __ ]
like he already did it so now you don't
support him no no i don't squirrel are
you team believe all children i might be
i want a shirt speaking of children i
think the one you're talking about is a
former star trek actor who accused the
actor of sexually assaulting him when he
was 14. what's his name see that's the
one i was thinking about
but you know what though he is a star
trek actor so
it is star trek
and i don't feel like anyone's trying to
bang star trek anthony rapp anthony rapp
yeah that's like dude he's in rent and
in uh adventures in babies has he just
been so he hasn't been in jail then he's
just been walking around freely like is
that how it works if he's like in trial
civil and they barely just what is
unconditional bail what is that like uh
is it like unconditional love or they're
gonna bail you out no matter what
unconditional love you know what i mean
like since it's you to unconditional
love it's like unconditional loves no
matter what they'll love you so it's
like unconditional bail is that no
matter what they're gonna pay bail you
out as opposed to conditional bill
unconditional bail is simpler and a bit
unstructured and unconditional bail
usually applied when the accused person
is a no flight risk
their charges are relatively
insignificant they don't seem like a
danger to society and they have a clean
criminal record is that enough is that
fair if anybody else was like no worries
of like [ __ ] raping
children earlier you guys are talking
about the stocks thing i feel like it's
the same thing i feel like if you're
famous and rich there's like a different
set of rules for you 100 yeah especially
in the states of course yeah and he's
only a threat to hollywood actors not
really the rest of us
yeah off broadway young male hollywood
off-broadway actors that's a threat i'm
not in his range of men that he wants to
get you know you gotta show your sad
card a little sad about that one well
i'm probably 20 years too old for him
that's the line of like it's like do you
value yourself well am i kevin spacey
[ __ ] like oh that's good that's a
good quality i could be naked in a room
with him and he'll be like get away you
disgust me you're an old man you're an
old man and then he knocks on the table
yeah just like that get away you old
gazer
dude i'm so [ __ ] petty i'd be like i
ain't gay right now but i'm gonna make
you hard bro because i ain't gonna play
like that like how much pride do you
have yeah i'm kevin spacey and i'm like
all right then show me what you got show
me your moves
yeah what do you do yeah yeah yeah yeah
like how do you seduce me kevin spacey
ty's really and jason you're going to go
next you're going to be the next guy
you're next in line
show them your boner afterwards yeah
think about what you're going to do to
get me kevin spacey you like little boys
this is my [ __ ] cowboy hat you like
little boys because they make you feel
good about yourself have you been with
us have you [ __ ] been with a real man
and have you seen a real man do this
oh
oh oh oh
yeah you know
bro i don't
i don't know know man
feel about this i mean i felt something
i don't know what it was but i felt
something oh okay your turn jason go
ahead he's kind of spacey
you have to try to you have to try to
get him off make him horny okay but
where are we remember we're in a hotel
room we're in a hotel room
i [ __ ] lick my nipples in front of
him yeah top that
um yeah what would i gotta so i i want
what i want him to have erection you
want to try to get him to be attracted
to a grown man
because that's not his type of you're
offended that you're not young enough
you got to be the first grown man that
he's attracted to defender
he's like i don't want you because
you're too old and you're like my pride
is hurt so i'm gonna get hard what are
you gonna do to get hard
that's the stipulation right
okay i just wanted to clarify the rules
just to make sure everybody's on the
same page yeah thank you i appreciate
that um
okay you say it say uh
you're you're too old for me you're too
old for me yeah but you didn't see my
penis
oh
that's it bro he wins dude looks like
that's a mess that's good he looks like
a child it's a soft penis yeah you guys
are good man that was that was really
good bart's turn yeah
and he looks hairless
to be honest he looks hairless i
honestly think that that was the best
answer i don't know all the time and we
should probably stop this game now
this would be safe
i think it's gone long enough yeah i
want to see what bart would do being in
such close proximity
no
you're making it too real
did you guys watch house of cards yeah
hell yeah it was sick i thought it was
really good yeah you know they took
stories from actual [ __ ] like what
happened in politics that are like like
who the rip shack was real [ __ ]
murdering people that are like trying to
about to tell on them and [ __ ] well that
that makes sense yeah oh man but i
thought our politics were like better
than other countries you know
i didn't know that that also makes sense
yeah i mean no no better as in like i
thought we were more honorable like i
didn't [ __ ] know that we were like
like politicians in our country don't
like commit fraud and murder no i
thought that was like for the third
world countries i didn't know like good
old america [ __ ] did that do third
world countries even really have
lobbyists the same way we do they just
they don't need to they they're just
like straight up with their corruption
exactly i kind of like that better yeah
they're just straight up hey i'm a
[ __ ] jack your [ __ ] you can't do [ __ ]
and you're like all right then but here
it's the same thing it's just they're
like what we gotta here's here's like
we're gonna give you your [ __ ] back and
then be honest you're like we're gonna
jack their [ __ ] yeah there's like all
this theater that you're watching yeah
semantics just like a good military coup
yeah yeah
everybody loves a good military i just
want to know how much
oil can i dump in the ocean
with and then just just let me just give
me a number you know and it's like
like 2 million 3 million okay fine and
then you pay it instead of like dude
here's all these [ __ ] well we got a
[ __ ] green you know we gotta be green
we're america and they're like oh really
so i can't dump this oil and they're
like well maybe if you like donate to my
campaign and they're like all right cool
cool give me a number goes oh i can't
tell you that you're like too much
guessing yeah yeah just let me be three
yeah tell me three million let me
[ __ ] make a pelican [ __ ] covered
in oil like you want to drop the oil off
your board you gotta get rid of this oil
man there's some logic to that you know
it's hard to follow but i'm with you
it's confusing man
but um my all-time favorite movie of
kevin spacey is k-pacs
so yeah let's go around the room
let's go favorite k-space movies it's
usually see him as as a bad guy
after you love him so much from k-packs
you're like he's like he is a good bad
guy in other movies though he's a good
bad guy in life yeah obviously like you
could tell like this [ __ ] is
dark i loved when he started working out
in american beauty to try and get a 17
year old high school chick like the idea
of being like this this is the this is
america's best actor right now that's
gonna get a best [ __ ] movie award
that's so true just a
[ __ ]
like midlife crisis
grown-ass male who's like about to cheat
on i mean it's method acting because he
was just imagining there were a 17 year
old boy yeah that's pretty cool i forgot
he's in glengarry glenn ross oh that's a
good movie too yeah really good what
about you jason what are your favorite
chemists not the best because i just the
last thing i remember he said
horrible bosses he was really funny
yeah but that wasn't even his his movie
but what's capex though he's an alien
he's an alien and then people are like
through the whole movie they're like
this guy's just [ __ ] crazy and then
they're like no he is an alien and he
gets into this insane asylum and [ __ ]
and then like they're like no no you
don't he is and everyone starts
believing that he's actually an alien
and then one day he looks into the sun
and he disappears and then everyone's
like i told you he went back home
oh so it ends and he really is an alien
nobody knows
oh it's like ambiguous at the end yeah
was he a homeless man that's crazy or
was he an alien what do you think same
thing as usual suspect he [ __ ] just
walks away just from a limp to a regular
walk
and k packs that's probably imagine just
being the same character in every single
like samuel jackson i feel like samuel
jackson is the same [ __ ] guy in every
movie not mace windu he's a he's samuel
l jackson as may swindu who's mace windu
dude he's a star wars he never said
[ __ ] even in the new [ __ ]
samuel jackson he calls it he says
mother father cocker spaniel and super
pets
or whatever the [ __ ] furry pause
kung fury kung paws
pause the fury pause the fury that's the
new movie he's in kung pao's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you